[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the true Geordie YouTube
channel today I respond to Connor
McGregor
that's funny now you've probably heard a
little bit about this but let me give
you a quick recap a couple of weekends
ago Conor McGregor did a series of
interviews that I reacted to where
Stevie Wonder could have told you the
man was off his head now the problem for
me is I'm the kind of person who will
say the thing that no one else is
actually saying but everyone can see and
that's probably why in the last six
months I've had Conor McGregor and Tyson
Fury both cussing me out no no
I'm the Creator I'm a Creator I'm the
Creator as I wasn't here to say it
happier okay you got the point Conor
McGregor did not look in a good way in
those interviews and I genuinely was
coming from a place of you know I used
to idolize this guy and for all I think
he's been a dick over the years and he's
ruined a lot of the way fans used to
look at him he's still a human and I
still wanted him to be the best version
of him and I wasn't coming at it from
like a hater point of view but obviously
Conor has probably seen a half a minute
social clip that being said that was
then and since then he's called me a lot
of names so let's hear what he had to
say five [__] bitched here who starts
a message like that that's not very
polite you're the [__] are you who am I
well for a start you've tagged me in the
Tweet that's like bringing up someone
and going hello and they go hello and
you go who are you and you go well you
called me you know fine well who I am
you've blocked this on your Twitter
you've blocked us on Instagram I
probably borrowed from that [__]
probably talked about all the time as
well your little bones victim looking
thing it's a strange one for an insult I
hate the idea that there's a little
young burns victim out there who
idolizes Conor McGregor and hears that
that's the tragedy here that little
harmless young man with a dream to
recover from his bones and Conor
McGregor is saying it's a bad thing do
you not have sympathy for burns victims
and as it happens this redness is a skin
condition anyway so joke's on you [__]
meme man who scalded you with a kettle
your fat [__] oh fat Shaman good one
good one remember when he used to be the
best wittiest trash talker in the game
if this isn't an example of why you
should stay off the gear kids I don't
know what is the man's brain's got a
mush you're fat nobody you little
feminine [__] of a thing color likes to
put himself across like he's this big
alpha male and he makes everyone feel
feminine bro what are you five for eight
eleven Stone I'm six foot four and 21
Stone literally I'm bigger and stronger
than you in every single conceivable way
I [__] women bigger than you Paul you
see Connor doesn't know what it's like
to shot me big and tall he has those
custom suits fitted just nicely for his
tiny little legs doesn't he those skinny
little brittle legs that snap like Twigs
why [__] [__] yeah keep my name out of
here stupid [__] how could we forget
this
[Music]
if this doesn't say you've got a problem
pal I don't know what does because how
[__] wrecked were you sick of seeing
your fat born face Scully fat he's using
head estrogen
it's funny because you always find that
what you're really thinking about will
come out a lot of the time in videos
where people make them ranting like this
and since Connor left the UFC testing
pool hormones have really been on the
brain can't think why though did you
need testosterone did you Connor to help
your little brittle bones heal up did
you oh my God you can't understand what
I'm saying
you've got subtitles under the [__]
thing saying exactly what I'm saying so
what are you saying
you have to laugh because I'm listening
to this thinking at no point did he say
I'm not on drugs
that is the first thing like if you have
a problem with what I'm saying which is
that I'm worried that he's on drugs and
he's going downhill rapidly then just
simply going mate don't worry about it
I'm not on drugs it's fine but in no
point does he say that I wonder why and
as it happens I'm not the only one to
have expressed concerns for Conor
McGregor it's literally in the Daily
Mirror here Conor McGregor fans Express
concern for UFC star after Monarch or
Grand Prix this is off the back of all
those interviews as well
foreign
does this look like a man who's ready
for his next UFC fight really now a lot
of viewers will have seen Connors and
Monaco right now he's on a yacht now
imagine you're him you're drinking
champagne you're enjoying the Sun the
babes are walking past you are living
your best life in that scenario where
you're on a Lamborghini yacht would you
be worried about some fat no-name
YouTuber talking [__] about you if he
was completely wrong no he would laugh
it off go about your day he hasn't got a
clue what he's talking about why would
you respond if I was completely wrong
the man is completely showing his ass
here I've clearly touched the nerve and
I'm clearly right even if I am right you
should be so happy within your life
having all of those things that what I
say would never trigger you to be that
angry that frustrated and the reality is
this is a classic case of you can have
everything but it doesn't make you happy
which is why he's constantly on the gear
and a lot of people have played this off
like oh he just likes a good time it's
just a one-off if that was the case I
would never have made a video about it
we've always known Conor McGregor likes
a bit of this and that and he has a good
type but that's not what he says now in
the interview that I was talking about
it was like 12 o'clock in the afternoon
and he was talking like this I'm the
Creator I'm a Creator I'm the Creator
he's talking like that early on in the
day this isn't the man who's just gone
out on a night out with the lads and
celebrating something this is a man
who's been on it from GetGo he has his
Kellogg's and his cocaine that's when
you've got a [__] problem and
unfortunately the [__] around him
who are probably on the [__] take
aren't man enough to have a [__]
straight conversation with him and as an
actual true fan of his in the past I'm
pointing it out like this guy needs
[__] help it's clear as this he's
talking about fighting Michael Chandler
Michael Chandler right now is the safest
money you're ever going to bet on a
fight in your life he is in no way ready
to fight anyone not even me and the
funniest thing is the way he's talking
about this in this video the way he
complained about Nate Diaz being too big
for him too strong for him at 170 pounds
mate I'm I'm 300 [__] pounds and
built like a rugby player I'm the size
of the guys who Floyd Mayweather and you
hire to protect them when you're walking
around in public I would pick Conor
McGregor up like a shopping bag with one
arm he is so small compared to me and I
know his fans are going to think he's
like Superman or whatever but they've
got weird classes for a reason bro I'm
more than twice the size of this man and
look if you want to do a charity fight
anything MMA boxing I don't really give
a [__] because I'm literally a giant
compared to you we'll donate the money
to Burns victims how about that anytime
anywhere any place I really don't care
someone needs to shut that [__] hole
in your face and unfortunately you spent
the majority of your career fighting
guys smaller than you where you had a
power advantage and the minute you moved
up away class you got found out big time
in the last seven years he's won one
fight man and the only guy he beat was
the most over the hill finished version
of Donald Cerrone who was basically
ready for a [__] old people's home
and the other three that he lost he lost
by finishes I'm telling you a classic
sign of a fighter in Decline is being
finished not just losing but being
consistently finished dust Emporia
[__] walked you down like a dog put
you on your back and beat the [__]
[__] out of you with ease this is a man
that you were once way better than but
you know why he did that because he
worked hard and you sat on a boat doing
Cork and drinking your [__] [__]
whiskey and the reality is in the fight
against Dustin the second one the minute
he became the nail instead of the hammer
he immediately was decimated he can't
take punishment man he's a front-runner
fight a classic front-runner fighter and
don't get me wrong I'm not a hater in
his prime I'd featherweight where he has
clearly had a massive power Advantage he
was unbelievable but you took that one
thing away from him and you say what you
get I mean look at the state of him does
this look like the kind of guy who's
ready to be a world champion again and
the funny thing about this is right I
used to get [__] for being too big of a
fan of Conor McGregor because I would
acknowledge all of the great things he'd
done but the reality is when he declined
in the cage I said it and when he acted
like a [__] outside of the cage I
said it when you look at the
controversies he's had on his Wikipedia
page there's more controversies in the
last seven years than there is fights
that's not an exaggeration driving
offenses which I mean he just doesn't
seem to give a [__] about driving jump
in the fence and another MMA event
getting into a fight the butt attack
that khabib namaga made of was on the
bus he smashed the dolly off the bus
shards of glass went into other fighters
who it cost them a shitload of money
Rose Nama Eunice a female fighter was in
quite a bit of danger in that moment I
mean she was injured he actually reached
out to apologize and she said no
apologize to my heavyweight UFC fight
her husband funny old thing Connor never
got in touch with him big bad Connor
didn't want to talk to the UFC
heavyweight did he the sexual assault
allegations of which there were a few
the pub assault where he hit that little
old man I mean supposedly like UFC
Legend and you're [__] hitting little
old man in a bar [__] joke man
another sexual assault arrest alleged
attack on a musician alleged attack on a
yacht where a 42 year old woman on his
yacht basically said that she was forced
to jump off the yacht to escape Conor
McGregor and had a broken arm in the
process and she could have actually died
if she hadn't been picked up by the
police in Spain for those who think I'm
out of order for pointing out his issues
with drugs right now the very same day
that he attacked me for suggesting that
he might have a problem he then tweets a
UFC Legend in Matt Brown who once
overdosed on heroin and calls him a
heroin addict great guy great guy to all
his little uh hero worshipers who think
he's Superman believe me he is very much
human and a very flawed one at that it's
all the little nasty messages I've heard
go [__] yourself because I just speak
the truth and I will continue to speak
the truth I don't care Tyson Fury slags
us off Conor MC drag our slices off
because there are too many or Slickers
in this [__] industry who are just
saying all the nice things and toeing
the lane because they want to get that
interview and I really don't give a [__]
because I don't idolize these people
they're just humans like me and you they
make mistakes and does any of this make
Connor the worst person in the world not
at all but when he acts great he wants
all the adulation well what comes with
that is when you act like a [__] you
also get criticism you can't have it one
way not the other that's just life I've
made a few jokes back to him because he
asked for it but you've got all the
[__] money in the world and got
everything in the world and he needs to
find some happiness because clearly he
isn't in that place right now because
his happy place was being on top of the
world and holding the belts and being
the champion and that is temporary and a
lot of people struggle to let that go
and he is a classic case a bit right
[__] now my advice give someone like
Ricky Hutton a phone call he'll [__]
sit you down and explain how you've got
to let it go unfortunately I think it's
going to result in him getting knocked
out at least a couple of more times
before he's willing to accept that but
we'll see what happens don't forget to
like the video subscribe to the true
Geordie YouTube channel and I'll see you
the next time one of these legendary
Fighters wants to punch me face and who
you kidding Connor you'll do nothing